good morning John sometimes I forget
that not everyone in America is like me
and in fact most people do not live
their lives on the Internet
there are lots of people in America who
still have dial-up internet who've never
streamed the video who think that lol
stands for lots of love which
tangentially is a very dangerous mistake
to make it can lead the emails like dear
Lynn I was so sorry to hear of the
passing of your wonderful golden
retriever and it's times like these that
we must take comfort in God's love Lal
Margaret so yeah Katherine's parents are
here visiting and they have never had a
high-speed Internet in their lives they
seem very interested in supportive when
I try to explain to them what it is that
I do but it's obvious that more or less
we're talking different languages
honestly I can't figure out why they're
so nice about it I mean if my daughter
married a dude who is like sorry I can't
go out to the lunch
I have to go talking to a camera and my
arms around I don't think I would be
very friendly to that guy and I have a
10 megabit per second download so they
don't get it but I guess they don't have
to because they're really nice about it
anyway so thanks to them for that also
Katherine's brother and her
sister-in-law and their son our nephew
who's 4 years old are also in town which
is mixture of big group of people and
John I have to tell you four-year-olds
in in whatever amount of time between
now and when Henry is 4 you've you've
got some preparations to do because Bill
Cosby was right
they have brain damage one second he's
like Uncle Hank I love you let's play go
fish and I'm like that sounds like a
wonderful idea let's play go fish and
then five minutes later I'm like do you
have any jacks and then he's all I will
torture your soul for an eternity of
hell I am now sitting as I make a noise
that will kill all the dolphins
the mostly you know aside from the
dolphin killing he's very fun seriously
though we hang out and we eat and he's
funny and he's cute and I've been going
to sleep way earlier than is natural for
my body he wakes up at 6 o'clock in the
morning every morning what kind of demon
does that a friend also I'm trying to
teach him the meaning of words like
perseverance and relaxation but he does
not get either of those ideas at all
trying to get the idea of relaxation
across to him is very confusing I think
it's this thing that you can do that's
actually not doing anything you just
don't do stuff you just chill which does
not compute because of the brain damage
and the perseverance he pretty much
would rather not be doing whatever it is
he's doing and he would like to be doing
whatever it is that he cannot do not
allowed why did this video turn into a
video about a four year old but I do
have to tell you one last thing he is
obsessed with his poops particularly
with the size of his poops and he also
assumes that likewise you will be very
interested in the size of his poops
anyway the slow pace of development of
human children is a side effect of our
reliance upon cultural and not genetic
evolution and that is the very thing
that makes people so amazing and so
awesome and so unique so I guess it
would be foolish of me to complain about
it
so everybody I think that my nephew was
curious how is your poop been lately
John I will see you on Monday